oh
it's crunchy and then weirdly soft
i think when you're eating that you
really know something died
[Music]
um i think i think american food is very
good they've not really nailed portion
control have they and that's why there's
so many facts
okay
i've got uh
licorice all sorts
um
as far as i remember
are all licorice
so all sorts
now i
hate licorice so i imagine this won't be
great will it
yeah licorice is still disgusting
even if you cover it in sugar
oh god
okay so this is toxic waste now imagine
you get more vitamins in a head butt
okay so this is
is it what is it sour candy
oh
oh god
oh crushed
what
well that's the face i do when i come
oh wow
i think that's won by some margin
because
that gets pleasant once you're through
the bitterness
where's the all sorts
come off
what do we got here we got um
we've got uh pork scratchings
versus beef jerky i'm vegan is that
gonna be a problem
[Music]
pork scratchings it's sort of like i
guess if you had to describe it it's pig
dandruff isn't it
oh
it's crunchy and then weirdly soft
i think when you're eating that you
really know something died
recommended daily allowance
none
none you shouldn't have any okay and
this is um
uh jack links
meat snacks
beef jerky
a uh a meat snack
is the sort of thing i thought i would
find on lad bible
turns out sort of a news website
who knew
um oh wow that's
okay so that
i mean it really feels like it should be
being sewn back onto something
okay so let's
[Music]
i think if these teeth were real i
wouldn't got through that
it's that's that i'd be honest with you
that is much more sort of succulent and
delicious than the pork scratching i
think america's one
okay cheese and crackers how tough could
this be so we've got um
jacob's crackers
what's this
el nacho grande nacho cheese sauce
what
why won't it move
[Music]
oh i mean it's yeah
that is um that's not a great
consistency is it for for food if you
were grouting a bathroom i reckon that
would win over the cheddar i mean cheese
and crackers we know what cheese and
crackers taste like right this is going
to be what is this a mild cheddar what
is it
yeah i mean great
and you came up with this idea yourself
to
give a celebrity some mild cheddar on a
cracker and just let the comedy pour out
of them
yeah
you're robbing a living
so i wonder who they're going to replace
you with
oh jesus
wow
okay
that's
genuinely awful
oh
wow god
yeah i think the uk has won there
[Applause]
no it tastes like medicine it tastes
like medicine yeah they were yeah this
one too yeah
no that's better really yeah yeah i
don't know what that is
that is iron brew it's um scottish i
believe yeah breathing scotland it's not
made by the people who do marmite
no no